eight y equals one over X that first one
we can write this in a much more general
way such as y equals a over X minus h
plus K okay so just to do a simple
example say we have y equals two over X
minus one plus three okay so here what
the to does if you start off with your
basic graph okay what the two does is
it's going to stretch the graph
vertically so that just means instead of
being like over here at one one now it's
going to be at one two okay
instead of being over at negative one
negative one you're gonna be at negative
one negative two so it's it's stretching
it okay so now your graph looks
something like this okay stretching in
the vertical direction but the one and
the three they pick up the graph and
they shift it left and right up and down
the one that's grouped with the X it has
the opposite effect on the graph if it's
minus one it actually shifts the graph
right wand and up three okay so each of
these points is going to shift right one
up three even the asymptotes themselves
are going to shift right one up three so
this is going to be right one up three
so now you can see your graphs gonna
look more like something like that okay
so that's the reciprocal function let's
look at the square root function say we
wanted to graph y equals negative two
square root of x plus two minus four
okay so what you can do is you can take
a look at the trance the translation
here so this is going to shift left 2
and down 4 so left 2 down 4 so we can
think of that as our starting point okay
and if we look at what's left this is
going to be like our core function okay
so our like our parent function the two
is going to stretch the graph the
negative is going to reflect the graph
so what we can do is we can make a table
instead of graphing from the origin like
we normally do we're going to graph from
the shift
point since everything's gonna be
shifted left 2 and down 4 so let's just
make a table pick some easy values like
0 1 & 4 square root of 0 is 0 times
negative 2 is 0 square root of 1 is 1
times negative 2 is negative 2 square
root of 4 is 2 times negative 2 is
negative 4 and we're going to plot these
points from here so right 1 down 2 right
4 1 2 3 4 down for right there and you
can see the graph is looks like that so
that if you want to do this in order you
want to describe the translation and the
transformation in order you would start
from the inside just like you're working
with the order of operations you'd say
this shifts left to okay so you start
off with your basic graph it shifts left
to it gets stretched by 2 times so it's
going to just going to go up faster like
that the negatives going to reflect it
over the x-axis okay and the negative 4
is going to shift it down 4 but as far
as graphing is concerned I would use a
method that I just showed you I would
consider the translation the shift first
think of that as your starting point
look at what the remainder of the
function and graph that make a table and
graph it from that that new starting
point and that's a quick and easy way to
get the graph I'll show you another
example let's pick another one let's
take y equals x cubed this time so y
equals x cubed and again we can think of
this in a more general way like y equals
a X minus H cubed plus K the H shifts at
left and right K shifts it up and down
and the a stretches it or compresses it
so let's just do this one y equals
one-half X plus 4 cubed minus 2
okay so what happens to the graph here
shifts left four down to the one half is
actually compressing it now if we want
to say it in order it actually shifts
left four we're giving the inside out
it's a vertical compression okay times a
half and then it's just down to but as
far as an easy way to graph it what I
would do is I would think about graphing
from the shifted origin which is left
four and down to okay think of that as
your starting point
and then we're going to just focus in on
what's left here y equals one-half X
cubed so I'm just going to make a table
pick some easy values like negative one
zero and one so a cube root of negative
x cubed negative one cubed is negative
one times 1/2 is negative 1/2
zero cubed is 0 times 1/2 is 0 1 cubed
is 1 times 1/2 is 1/2 so from here I'm
going to go left one down 1/2 0 0 right
1 up 1/2 and I didn't graph a whole lot
of points here but the graphs gonna look
like that so the 1/2 compressed it and
the 4 shift it left 4 in it negative 2
shifted it down too so you can do this
with any parent function you can stretch
it and compress it and you can shift it
left and right up and down just think of
it in a more general way like we've been
doing these other ones so this has been
an introduction to parent functions and
transformations I'll see you in the next
video